[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today San Jose
what do you have to say about it Dominic
hi thank you so much for taking my call
guys
um so basically uh I'm a bit of uh at
first I call the Flyers remorse but I
think it's more a buyer's deal because
it's something that like I can justify
but it's something that I just don't
think is was quite in line with what did
you buy Dominic we can't wait to hear
this
I bought a 2020 Tesla Model 3. 2020
Tesla Model 3 and then what's that set
you back
it sent me back uh like out the door it
was uh 41.3 oh boy you bought everything
and you even are talking like the car
guy out the door he told you I'll get
this for you right now Dominic out the
door 41 000 you're like yes please well
what's your income
no you didn't tell me that I had to
figure it out myself but um I make uh
115 before taxes oh yeah what's the
payment on this beauty
it is 6.87 a month oh gosh
okay I gotta get a Pepto-Bismol J
takeover well technically we would tell
people that anything going down in value
like a vehicle you shouldn't do more
than 50 percent have more than 50
percent of your annual income tied up in
that so you're under that I think my
guess is just maybe you've never had a
car payment that's this costly and
you're feeling it and I don't like car
payments period but what was your car
situation before you got into this Tesla
so I actually had a paid off car that's
what it is it's only yeah and I and at
the time I was like yes I just want to
not have a car payment I was like 11k I
paid it off in like a couple months
because I didn't have a little cash
right on hand but um basically recently
in recent times uh I don't know I guess
I started thinking about like oh maybe I
would enjoy having something a bit more
luxurious you know rather than driving
something so old and I convinced myself
into doing it I didn't and I'm like and
I did that the math and I was like yeah
I can afford it and you know I went
through with it and now I'm sitting here
and I just looking at that much debt
coming from having zero debt whatsoever
is just like my heart's sank so you
called us so why did you call us Dominic
what's the question in here
um I'm kind of trying to figure I'm kind
of between two decisions so I talked
about it with my fiance and she is
telling me that it's probably just best
to keep the car just pay it off as quick
as possible because I I'm able to pay
off the car uh in less than 30 months if
I just make double payments and I can
afford that I can count for that when I
was doing the math and she likes right
the other options
let's throw that out there and she likes
riding in the Tesla come on yeah no
she's like please don't get rid of the
car I love your car all right what's the
second option we got about a minute we
want to help you out what's the second
option
second option is to sell the car
privately or trade it in and then just
get a cheaper car what can you get for
it if you sell it
um privately about uh Reserve uh say I
would say like 31 so I'd be losing like
10 grand off of like yeah you know what
it's really there's not a wrong answer
here it's your only debt like I said
you're kind of I I don't want anybody to
have a car note I don't want them to go
into that but you're kind of under that
threshold
um you just hate having the payment and
I don't blame you because you went from
not having any payments to having a
payment and it sucks so for you you know
if your girlfriend is like get out of
the car and you're like get out of the
car then sell it you know take that
stupid tax of ten thousand dollars and
you're just gonna have to bite the
bullet on that and then get into
something in cash or start saving
towards that so you can make it happen
that's what I would do
um yikes you know I'm telling you I mean
he's got the money if you wanted to just
write it out and pay it off I I think
I'd get after it I think I'd I'd pay it
off and learn this lesson turn that hate
into a newfound
emotion that you can't even describe to
get out of this thing faster than you
could possibly imagine